okay let's get to investing
um so this week in the news obviously
this past week was the whole
gamestop wall street bets short sale
fiasco and then a couple days ago
you have elon musk and who and tesla
invests
1.5 billion dollars into bitcoin so i
know you've been very clear just now
that uh you're you're a big fan of
bitcoin i actually saw your interview
with
raul paul and he's the guy that got you
kind of over the hump on bitcoin and
obviously you're a big advocate of
commodities like
gold and silver so let's let's talk to
the young americans out there in their
20s or 30s who have not started
investing yet for whatever reason
and let's say they've saved up some
money they have an emergency fund you
know they got a little cushion
and let's say they have ten thousand
dollars to get started
investing robert where do you recommend
they start first when it comes to
investing
i always recommend invest in your head
and your brain that's why i have
tremendous respect for what
patrick beth david and you guys have
done you're taking education from real
teachers
the trouble with academics is their
fakes just like gamestop is a fake asset
but you look at they tried you know the
the reddit guys god bless them
and the who the other guys robin hoods
they tried to mess with silver the
trouble was silver silver is a real
asset
gamestop's a fake asset mm-hmm
manipulated
messing with silver the richest guys on
earth
use silver nobody wants game stock
game stop i don't know what it's called
right why do the richest guys on
on earth utilize silver or gold in that
okay why silver silver is an industrial
metal it's used
you know it's going to be used to green
you deal tesla is going to use it in
batteries
it's medical water purification just
study silver
i started saving silver in 1964 when i
was 16 years old
because i picked up a little dime and
the dime had copper around the edge of
it
that was the first time there were
faking money
and at that point it was gresham's law i
i'm 16 years old i don't know anything
but i do know fake i do know fake
teachers
and i do know fake money this here is
fake money
this is the us dollar in a few years
so so i just think as as
young people what does school teach you
about money be a day trader
you want to be able to do that you got
to be crazy
so to piggyback on on your point
obviously i agree with you
100 on the best investment is investing
in yourself obviously warren buffett is
famous for saying that
investing into your brain investing into
knowledge investing in robert kiyosaki's
book richard and other books that we can
talk about
but let's talk about like actual hard
asset asset allocation are you actually
saying
that young people if they're going to
start investing may want to look into
silver
first and foremost is that what you're
suggesting
well as you know bitcoin made the move
with elon
and gold is pretty stable right now
because it is controlled by the biggest
guys
silver is used by industry it's using
batteries
you know bring you deals coming up and
all this
and it's suppressed you know you know
you weren't on wall street
it's a thousand percent manipulated
and so then they're all the shorts are
holding down
the price of silver because you know as
that's not it's not the
if silver goes up the business models of
apple
toshiba all the electronic companies
blow out the window so they've got to
suppress the price
of silver and you know
that can only last for so long so i
you know you don't have to go to college
to save gold and silver
all i did was a kid which i just put it
in a bag you know
i would i would take a dollar and girls
1964.
i go to the bank and i take out like 10
bucks and get a roll of dimes
and i'd go through the dimes and
anything that had copper on it i gave it
back to the
bank and i kept them on the no cop print
so i had a whole pile of silver i was a
rich kid
but nobody knew it because everybody
thought the dime was a dime it was fake
dimes
so it's just you know it's not that hard
it is common sense
gotcha i'm writing i'm taking notes uh
by the way robert i got
silver with a big circle on it thank you
for watching this short clip if you want
to see the full
episode check it out right here and if
you have not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here